au milieu des années 1960 un chercheur
en informatique du nom de Joseph
wezenbaum fait une expérience du
concertante
wezenbaum travaille ou mit la célèbre
université de technologie de la côte est
des États-Unis dans le domaine du
Natural linguage processus c'est-à-dire
qu'il s'intéresse à la manière dont les
utilisateurs communiquent avec les
premiers ordinateurs de l'époque qui
sont des grosses machines on est dans
les années 60 et à la manière dont les
ordinateurs interprètent le langage
humain
pour étudier cette question il crée un
petit programme qu'il appelle ELISA
qui imite une conversation entre un
psychiatre et son patient
le programme est vraiment basique Elisa
repère dans les phrases des utilisateurs
des mots clés
et déclenche en fonction des réponses
préprogrammées par exemple si vous lui
dites je n'en peux plus de ma mère
Elisa vous répondra parlez-moi de votre
famille parce que le programme a repéré
l'usage du mot mère
s'il ne repère pas de mots clés
particuliers il va reformuler votre
affirmation en question si vous lui
dites les hommes sont tous les mêmes
Élisa vous répondra pourquoi dites-vous
que les hommes sont tous les mêmes
on est très loin du niveau de
sophistication de chat gipiti et
pourtant l'expérience va être
profondément marquante pour Waze
car les participants à son expérience
vont développer une forme d'attachement
au programme il lui demande de pouvoir
continuer à échanger même une fois que
l'expérience est terminée
certains vont même aller jusqu'à
exprimer une forme de de dépendance
émotionnelle à l'égard du programme
la propre assistante de wezembe qui est
pourtant tout à fait au courant qu'elle
échange avec un programme informatique
et qui sait très bien comment fonctionne
ce programme passe de longues heures à
discuter avec Elisa et on vient à lui
confier des choses très personnelles
wezenbaum est marquée par l'expérience à
tel point que 10 ans plus tard il
publiera un livre sur les dangers de
l'informatique et de l'intelligence
artificielle
ce qui l'inquiète particulièrement
c'est la manière dont un programme
informatique peut même nipuler le
comportement d'un utilisateur
sans que celui-ci s'en rende compte
et avec une facilité des concertante
l'expérience d'Eliza elle est fondatrice
pour tout un tas de chercheuses et de
chercheurs qui dans les années 70 80 90
vont eux aussi développer des programmes
pour chercher à influencer le
comportement des utilisateurs
25 ans plus tard sur la côte ouest des
États-Unis
un jeune doctorant en psychologie
sociale du nom de budget fog et lui
aussi persuadé que les ordinateurs
peuvent influencer les comportements des
gens
il imagine toute une série d'expérience
afin d'identifier
quels éléments de design de conception
des programmes
et tu as même d'activer des leviers
psychologiques chez les utilisateurs
après sa thèse ils fonde le Standford
persuasif technologies Lab le
laboratoire des technologies persuasives
afin d'enseigner aux étudiants de
Stanford les résultats de ses recherches
fog
est persuadé c'est sa conviction
profonde que les technologies peuvent
faire le bien lui il imagine des
programmes qui aident les fumeurs à
arrêter de fumer qui poussent les
adolescents à manger plus de fruits et
légumes ou qui aident à améliorer la
productivité au travail
et c'est pas tout à fait ça qui va se
passer
au milieu des années 2000 c'est cours
sont très populaires sur le campus de
Stanford à tel point que fog va essayer
d'adapter ses préceptes à la nouvelle
économie des réseaux sociaux qui émerge
cette époque là
en 2007 il crée un cours
surnommé la Facebook classe et qui
deviendra une légende de la Silicon
Valley d'après la presse spécialisée
dans ce cours
phoque demande à ses étudiants de
construire des applications qui seront
hébergés sur Facebook ce que permettent
de faire le réseau social à l'époque par
exemple des jeux avec la consigne
suivante
utilisez des notions de psychologie
comportementale pour créer les
applications qui attireront le plus
d'utilisateurs
10 semaines après le début de
l'expérience les étudiants de FOG
ont créé des applications qui ont réuni
16 millions d'utilisateurs
et comme ils ont compris qu'ils
pouvaient monétiser leurs applications
ils ont au passage
amassés un butin de 1 million de dollars
de revenus publicitaires
alors sortie de Stanford les étudiants
de Fogg vont aller grossir les rangs des
principales compagnies de la Silicon
Valley comme
uber Google Facebook ou Netflix
l'un de ces anciens étudiants faudra une
entreprise dont vous a peut-être entendu
parler Instagram
un autre publiera la bible du marketing
digital des années 2010 le livre hooked
pour hameçonner sous-titré
créer des produits qui façonnent des
comportements
vous voyez venir alors que fog voulait
que les gens arrêtent de fumer ils
mangent plus de fruits et légumes il a
permis à de jeunes ingénieurs aux dents
longues de s'inspirer des apports de la
psychologie comportementale pour créer
les technologies les plus addictives qui
n'est jamais été inventée dans
l'histoire
ils ont associé aux réseaux sociaux des
mécanismes de captation de la tension et
de rentabilisation de la tension dont le
principe est le suivant cherchez à nous
faire passer le plus de temps sur les
plateformes
pour que nous soyons exposés à un
maximum de publicité
par exemple savez-vous pourquoi sur
Facebook sur Instagram ou sur Twitter
les files d'actualité ne se terminent
jamais
pour permettre la pratique du scroll
infini pour que l'on perde la notion du
temps lorsqu'on est n'utilise ces
applications et que on y passe un
maximum de temps
de la même façon savez-vous pourquoi
lorsque vous regardez une vidéo sur
Youtube ou Netflix la vidéo suivante se
lance automatiquement
mais pour nous empêcher de prendre la
décision de passer à une autre activité
lorsque vous discutez avec un ami sur un
une appli de messagerie comme Messenger
WhatsApp et que votre ami est en train
de vous écrire un message vous voyez
trois petits points rebondir
le but de ces trois petits points c'est
de vous tenir en haleine pour que vous
patientez le temps que le message
s'affiche et quand le message s'est
affiché un petit check apparaît en
dessous pour indiquer à votre
interlocuteur que vous avez vu le
message et pour vous vous sentiez obligé
d'y répondre
tous ces éléments de design de
conception des programmes ne doivent
rien au hasard
ils ont été pensés conçus et mis en
œuvre pour capter notre temps de cerveau
disponible
mais alors peut-être me répondrez-vous
oui mais après tout capter l'attention
d'un public et la rentabilité
n'est-ce pas le modèle économique des
médias en général
la phrase que je viens de prononcer sur
le temps de cerveau disponible vous aura
peut-être évoqué une célèbre citation
d'un ancien PDG TF1
et de la même façon on pourrait aussi
bien revenir au 19e siècle à l'âge d'or
de la presse pour constater que à cette
époque les titres rivalisent de une plus
scandaleuse les unes que les autres pour
attirer l'attention du chaland et se
démarquer des concurrents dans les
kiosques parisiens alors qu'est-ce qui
change vraiment aujourd'hui avec les
réseaux sociaux
ce qui change c'est que dans l'histoire
des médias ce sont toujours les contenus
qui ont eu pour fonction de capter notre
attention par leur sensationnalisme
aujourd'hui
ce sont les architectures d'information
c'est le design des applications qui
occupent cette fonction et donc qui
applique le sensationnalisme non pas au
contenu mais à la manière de les mettre
en valeur ces contenus
très bien mais peut-être me direz-vous
mais lorsque nous passons une heure sur
TikTok ou sur Instagram alors que nous
nous étions jurés d'y faire une pause de
deux minutes
personne ne nous met un pistolet sur
latent pour nous disant scroll passe
encore les vidéos on passe plus de temps
personne ne nous dit ça alors où est le
problème
le problème il est que à l'échelle des
sociétés ces mécanismes de captation de
l'attention ont des effets toxiques
sur le fonctionnement des démocraties
par exemple l'algorithme du fil
d'actualité de facebook va promouvoir
les contenus qui génèrent le plus de
colère le plus d'indignation parce que
ce sont les émotions qui suscitent le
plus de réactions de la part des usagers
l'exposition en continu à des vies
parfaites sur Instagram créer à grande
échelle des mécanismes de dépréciation
collective et de sous-estimation de soi
et les adolescents en sont les premières
victimes
la cyberdépendance fait son entrée dans
la nomenclature de l'Organisation
Mondiale de la Santé et nous nous
continuons de culpabiliser nous
continuons de penser que si nous passons
autant de temps à utiliser ces
applications c'est parce que nous ne
savons pas nous maîtriser
alors que le problème il est collectif
il est même politique
j'ai bien plombé à l'ambiance là avant
de terminer ou plutôt avant que l'on
parte sur nos écrans je voudrais
terminer avec une petite note d'espoir
car sur le front de l'économie de
l'attention les choses bougent les
pouvoirs publics se saisissent de ce
dossier en Europe entrera bien trop en
vigueur le DJ tal services actes le
nouveau cadre réglementaire européen qui
vit justement à imposer des nouvelles
normes aux plateformes de réseaux
sociaux ils visent entre autres à
interdire ce qu'on appelle les Dark
patterns les interfaces trompeuses et
manipulatrices
et ils vise aussi interdire le marketing
ciblé à destination des adolescents
le monde de la publicité se mobilise les
annonceurs font pression sur les
plateformes pour qu'elle contrôle
davantage la toxicité des contenus
qu'elles héberge
la société civile n'est pas en reste les
usagers menacent de quitter les
principales plateformes et de migrer
vers de nouveaux services on l'a bien vu
cette année avec le rachat de Twitter
parallèle musk
et même le monde de la tech est mobilisé
en proposant des alternatives aux
grandes plateformes des alternatives qui
reposent sur un principe de design
éthique respectueux de l'attention des
usagers et de leur donner personnel
alors dans ce contexte à quoi
ressembleront les réseaux sociaux de
demain
il fait aucun doute que nous
continuerons à utiliser des applications
des outils des logiciels qui nous
permettent de nous exprimer de débattre
de partager des contenus
les réseaux sociaux ont permis d'ouvrir
le débat public à de nouvelles voies
ils ont permis de faire connaître de
nouvelles idées
ils ont permis aux citoyens de se
connecter et de s'auto-organiser et il
ne fait aucun doute qu'on ne reviendra
pas en arrière
simplement ces réseaux sociaux
fonctionneront peut-être sur des
principes différents
il reposeront peut-être sur un design
éthique dans lequel les participants
peuvent reprendre un peu de contrôle sur
la manière dont les algorithmes leur
diffusent des informations peut-être
pourront-ils paramétrer ces algorithmes
peut-être verrons nous dans les années à
venir émerger des réseaux sociaux
publics comme nous avons aujourd'hui des
chaînes de télévision publiques ou des
stations de radio public
ces régions sociaux publiques seront à
but non lucratif ils pourront être
détenus par des associations ou par des
organismes de recherche
comme pour les chaînes de télévision
publique et les stations de radio public
les conditions de la indépendance par
rapport à l'État seront garantis par la
loi
leur gouvernance sera participative et
les usagers pourront participer à
décider des règles de publication et à
leur mise en application
leur design sera transparent leurs
audits leur pardon leurs algorithmes
seront auditables afin que nous
puissions savoir quel type d'usagers
voit quel type de contenu et pourquoi
alors est-ce que est-ce que c'est
idéaliste que de penser ça
dans un article devenu célèbre la
chercheuse américaine Zineb to sexy
compare l'industrie de la tech
aujourd'hui avec l'industrie de
l'automobile au début du 20e siècle
Google a 25 ans Facebook faitra ses 20
ans l'année prochaine
twitter vient de souffler ses 15 bougies
et à ce moment-là de l'histoire de
l'industrie automobile il y avait pas de
ceinture de sécurité il y avait pas
d'airbag dans les voitures il y avait
pas de ralentisseur sur les routes
ce ne sont pas les industriels qui ont
décidé d'inventer le code de la route
c'est la société et c'est représentants
qui ont décidé d'inventer de nouvelles
règles du jeu pour se protéger
le numérique nous plonge dans
une forme de présent permanent
mais si nous faisons un pas de côté et
que nous regardons l'histoire des
technologies nous comprendrons bien vite
que si les technologies ne sont pas
neutres
elles ne sont pas non plus immuables
nous pouvons les déconstruire pour les
réinventer
merci de votre attention merci merci
[Applaudissements]